hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
i know two episodes in two days
i'm very pleased that a lot of you
enjoyed yesterday's episode how
interesting are the wild and surprising
creative uses for ai
it was one of my favorite episodes to
make so be sure to check it out after
this
so the topic in today's episode i
thought was pretty important and it had
to be timely
so that's why you're seeing this second
episode right after the last one
tesla motors has been in the headlines
for many reasons recently
from parabolic stock prices to a ceo who
has extracted rage from mobs on twitter
but in this episode we'll take a quick
look at some of the recent announcements
on future plans for the company
if tesla can actually achieve what
they're talking about it's going to take
them from a specialized motor company
to mainstream all the while helping
battery technology along the way
let's take a look you are watching
cold fusion tv
[Music]
in a tesla event dubbed battery day elon
musk
and senior vice president and engineer
drew baglino described in detail
a plan for a new generation of electric
vehicle batteries
and it's not a plan that rests on a
single innovation
some research project that'll never see
the light of day it's a plan
that has taken creative engineering and
industrialization across
every facet of what makes a cell into a
battery pack from raw material to the
finished thing
they'll be more powerful longer lasting
and produced in-house
musk stated that all this will reduce
costs and bring the sale price of tesla
electric cars
closer in line to gasoline-powered cars
tesla's new larger cylindrical cells
dubbed
4860 will provide five times more energy
six times more power and a 14 reduction
in price per kilowatt hour
we are starting to ramp up manufacturing
of these cells
at our pilot 10 gigawatt hour production
facility just around the corner
yeah although prototypes are working
full production is about three years
away according to the presentation
in 2018 panasonic battery shortages
caused some delays in production
at this moment tesla realized that they
can't rely on external partners forever
they're going to keep existing partners
around for a while longer but eventually
they're gonna have to do things on their
own elon said that tesla will build a
new plant in north america
reducing supply chain costs and
simplifying cathode production
tesla wants to do everything in-house to
streamline the process from raw
materials
all the way to the final product
production of battery elements is
estimated to use
10 times less energy thanks to some
manufacturing techniques acquired from
maxwell technologies
it's also making improvements to the
process that would make cathodes
76 cheaper and will also produce zero
wastewater
combined efforts in streamlining the
production line could see a plant with
an output of one terawatt hour of energy
in a smaller footprint than what a plant
that only outputs 150
gigawatt hours would have
more localized production is estimated
to reduce the number of miles traveled
from transporting materials by 80
further saving costs and emissions
and just doing that just localizing our
cathode supply chain and production
we can reduce miles traveled by all the
materials that end up in the cathode by
which is huge for cost yeah i mean to be
clear cathode production would be part
of
our the tesla cell production plant so
then we should obviously
on-site lithium conversion as well which
is what we will do
using a new process that we're going to
pioneer that's a sulfate free process
again skip the intermediate
with all of these efforts combined tesla
expects a 54
increase in range while reducing the
cost per kilowatt hour by 56
range increase we're unlocking up to 54
increase in range for our vehicles and
energy density for our energy products
56 reduction in dollars per kilowatt
hour at the battery pack level
the newer batteries are expected to be
in the cyber truck roadster 2.0
and semi-truck vertical integration
makes this all possible allowing for
more control and customization to make
the whole system as efficient as
possible
an advantage i don't think many other
electric car companies have right now
tesla is also building its own cell
manufacturing facility
at its new factory in germany in
addition to the new plant in fairmont
california
tesla is also planning to eliminate the
use of cobalt in its cathodes
and this is even though tesla's existing
batteries use very little
cobalt is often mined under terrible
conditions that violate human rights
the aim is to replace the cobalt with
nickel for their higher quality
batteries
cobalt is also one of the most expensive
battery materials
so getting rid of it will also reduce
costs
[Music]
recycling the batteries was also a big
part of the plan
it was stated that eventually there's
not going to be a need to mine new raw
materials
as recycling existing batteries will
have better yield for materials versus
mining
and at that point we have an awesome
resource in those batteries to recycle
to make new batteries so we don't need
to do any more mining at that point and
you can see why
the the difference in the the value of
the
of the material coming back from the
vehicle versus the ground you'd always
go to the vehicle
and we recycle 100 of our vehicle
batteries today
great yeah i mean to date it's been done
by third parties but uh
we think we can we can recycle the
batteries more effectively
especially since uh our batteries we're
making the same battery
as the thing we're recycling so uh
whereas like third-party recyclers have
to consider batteries of all kinds
elon stated that it was critical to
reduce the cost of the cars
he mentioned that affordability was key
to scaling
one of the things that troubles me the
most is that we don't yet have a truly
affordable car
and we need to do something about this
curve this cur the curve of
of the cost per kilowatt hour of
batteries is not improving fast enough
we give it we've given us a lot of
thought over many years
to say okay how can we radically improve
the cost per kilowatt hour
curve while average electric vehicle
prices have been decreasing in recent
years
thanks to changes in battery composition
they're still far more expensive than
regular cars
it's estimated that the battery makes up
a third of an electric vehicle's costs
some researchers estimate that for
electric cars to be as viable as
gasoline cars
the cost of a battery pack has to be 100
per kilowatt hour
tesla's battery packs currently cost 156
dollars per kilowatt hour as of 2019
so efforts to reduce the cost of
batteries is paramount to the long term
goal
these new batteries by tesla will go
towards building a 25 000
electric car uh so uh
we're we're confident that long term we
can design and and manufacture
a compelling 25 000 electric vehicle
you know this this has always been our
dream from the beginning of the company
about three years from now we're
confident we can make a very calm
very compelling 25 000 electric vehicle
uh that's also fully autonomous and when
you think about
the twenty five thousand dollar price
point you have to consider how much how
much less expensive it is to own
an electric vehicle yeah so actually it
it's it it becomes even more affordable
at that 25 000
price point he's expecting to have such
a car available in about three years
tesla is usually always behind schedule
so maybe we can expect such a car in
about four or five years
in the long term the company is also
targeting an annual production of 20
million vehicles
or almost twice as much as volkswagen
auto group sold last year
and they were the world's best-selling
individual auto company
so according to musk and drew all of
what was said in the presentation
is working in principle and on a small
scale most of the remaining work
involves scaling it was also announced
that structural changes would be made to
how the cars are actually built
batteries will now be part of the car to
save space and allow for even more
battery cells
elon has been teasing a new souped up
model s for a while
the car will be a step above the
ludicrous model the specs are insane
it's going to have
over 520 miles of range get from 0 to 60
in under 2 seconds
and have a top speed of 200 miles per
hour
in testing around the track laguna seca
this new model beat the previous tesla
record by 18 seconds
the price listed on tesla's website is
about 140 000
and is going to be available in late
[Music]
so in summary this event housed a lot of
promises
54 increased range while reducing the
cost per kilowatt hour by 56
plus a recyclable supply chain and
minimal environmental impact
is a tall order it seems optimistic
but the tesla team has been proving
people wrong for over a decade
so if anyone can do it it's going to be
them so i'm wishing them all the best
because ultimately
such efforts are good for everyone
though the competition is heating up
with lucid air
porsche and rivian all making a splash
in the electric market but if tesla can
do what they say
this is going to put them a great deal
ahead on the flip side
nikola motors seems to be crashing and
burning after their concept electric
truck was revealed to be rolling down a
hill
and not actually driving as it was
misleadingly implied in an advertisement
i'm talking to some people that
contributed to a scathing report by
hindenburg research
it was picked up by cnbc and other
financial media
it was the very same report that made
the ceo of nikola motors resign
so please be patient with the production
of this episode though do subscribe if
you want to see that story
so anyway what do you guys think about
the tesla announcement
are you excited do you think it's
feasible to make a 25 000
electric car or are you more skeptical
let me know in the comment section below
i'd also like to add that i don't own
any tesla stock
right so thanks for watching if you do
want to see anything on science
technology business or history
definitely subscribe to cold fusion
you'll find a lot of interesting stuff
on here there's going to be another
episode this week number three
next time we're going to look at
nanoparticles that dissolve plaque
in arteries and may prevent heart
disease the same topic that i mentioned
at the end of yesterday's video
so stay tuned i'll see you again next
time for the next episode
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion it's new thinking
you